from The Wall Street Journal Biden
planning to ask Congress for $100
billion funding package for Israel and
Ukraine 100 billion do get your
contracts out where's that money coming
from so we've already spent $13 billion
on Ukraine alone since February 2022
we've given Israel I think 38 million
starting with a deal in 2016 that was
like 38 Milli billion billion rather
over a decade over3 and5 billion dollar
so we had there was a new in between the
United States government and Israel uh
for military financing the FMF OU that
we do with Israel that we've done now
for decades and that's part of our
funding for them to be able to uh ensure
their uh qualitative military Edge I'm
I'm cool with that money honestly yeah
and I and I and I'm totally support that
I don't know how this money breaks down
the 100 billion like who goes cool the3
my problem is I'm I'm into like we need
to fix this country right now and I I'm
supportive of Israel striking back I'm I
pray for the innocent people on both
sides but I've been like reporting
around this country so much this past
year and we are a mess yeah you're
everything's collapsed I was in East
Palestine like a month after the
explosion they they're still in need
righta burned down they're shutting down
I mean look CVS's are shutting down
targets Walgreens all shutting
down was that was an OP
but but yes that is also very very bad
uh Bank branches are shutting down
across the board us infrastructure is
collapsing there's this viral video
right now of this woman talking she's a
Canadian by the way but you know we're
close enough neighbors she's talking
about how she wanted to get a salad in
some ribs and it was it was $45 and she
was shocked now I think one of the
problems here is that she blames the
grocery store for the high price which
is like that's like a Trudeau issue but
now that's Canada there I want everyone
understand there's another viral video
that uh um I I uh I think I recorded
this for Friday so I don't think it's up
on my channel yet but it's a guy
comparing uh uh prices from Costco a
year on and it's like the cost of rice
has doubled the cost of mayonnaise has
doubled the cost of beans has doubled
and he's like yo they're saying
inflation is only a couple percent all
of the food Staples chicken the prices
are up
700% you spent another 100 billion
dollars we don't have that money well
and it's not just printing off more
money which we've been consistently
doing through the inflation reduction
act and all the other trillions of
dollars that we've been spending um
because of Joe Biden and the Democrats
and what they've been doing in Congress
secondarily to that is you have to
remember part of this is what does how
does food travel how does it get to you
it gets to you by truck it gets to you
by what are those powered by fossil
fuels fossil fuels right and what are
the Democrats trying to stop the
production of things like oil gas coal
things of that nature so they've created
essentially artificial scarcity in the
marketplace around things like oil which
then creates look the demand is there
supply and demand the supply is High um
or pardon me the demand is high and the
supply is low because of the artificial
scarcity and the regulations they put
into place around the fossil fuel
industry so to be able to transport
those items it's a pass through cost
it's going to go down to the consumer
it's going to always hit the consumer
it's a hidden tax you all are paying
right now for this war on the fossil
fuel industry literally at the grocery
store it's all part of the inflation
that's happening it's not just all the
money that they're printing but it's
also what they're doing in the energy
industry which literally transports
everything that you buy when I was in oh
sorry when I was in California it was $7
for a gallon of unlet gas and it all
started when Biden shut down the
Keystone Pipeline yes yeah you can
actually you can actually look at the
moment when Biden is inaugurated not
even the election and you can see like
an inversion in wages and inflation and
people are like oh it's not Joe Biden's
fault it's Trump's fault because they're
his policies rolling into effect it's
like no no no no you can actually I
think it was like Wall Street Journal
showed this graph and it's like it just
flips as soon as he starts signing these
executive orders and people are asking
how did shutting down Keystone caus gas
prices and prices to Skyrocket when
Keystone wasn't even transporting oil
these are people I'm sorry they're first
order thinkers and this is what happens
when you get a woman who's like I blame
the grocery store for the high prices
right these people don't realize here's
what happens keep stone is being built
to transport oil from Canada into uh
through the US and then it goes south
down uh to the gulf or whatever for
transport distribution this means that
when you're looking at the market
futures you're like okay do we have
enough supply for demand well Keystone's
been shut down which means we are now
going to fall short of Supply with
demand increasing prices are going to go
up then what happens people are buying
saying we better buy now which causes
prices to drive straight up yes now your
gas costs more money because Joe Biden
is negatively impacting the entire uh
industry and infrastructure and then we
tapped the Strategic petroleum Reserve
drained it drained that so stupid yeah
we drained that one it's like I I I
remember watching that happen and I was
just like stop doing stop doing that and
and and and and I just want to point
this all out and loop it all back into a
nice little bow all of the things Joe
Biden did have put us on the path for
total Annihilation if it comes to uh uh
International Warfare yes we're we're
not ready we you know the Strategic
petroleum are spent down right
completely spent down and Trump had
filled it up and Trump had filled up and
then the policies that you've had these
globalists pushing for years as it
relates to jobs in the United States and
deindustrialization like in the United
States right now we can make just over
16,000 artillery shells a month that's
what we can do the ukrainians are
spending 60,000 a month so we're
transferring literally out of stock po
over to them which is affecting our
Readiness down the road the Pentagon has
a plan to increase this to like
24,000 uh 24,000 artillery shells a
month in the next 3 years does that
sound like we're ready for anything like
of course we're not ready not exactly
yeah we we rushed I mean just into this
service tech economy type thing that
we're living in now offshore all of our
manufacturing jobs if we had a World War
II situation pop up here again is there
any way we'd be ready to um
industrialize the economy to be able to
build the uh type of Machinery equipment
and military equipment that we would
need to defend ourselves of course not
the only thing we'd have is like
Facebook and we could post a comment
being like the Chinese are invading this
sucks you the only thing we just meme
about it yeah yep it's terrible it'll go
down in the history of books as we all
wied ourselves to death right I'm really
upset about our new Chinese Communist
overlords they're making me eat you know
bricks and bugs and the bugs well
there's definitely the bugs but it does
make me think of like the King Dynasty
right which was the wasn't that like the
isolationist dynasty in China and they
were isolationist for a long time and
then they emerged at the end of that and
they were like oh now we're ready to
rejoin the world and they had gotten
their a lot of their thing together in
terms of like who they were as a people
and Americans we don't know who we are
as a people you know I was watching this
video on Twitter today this woman was
like I was overseas and these are all
the things I hate about America now and
I was just like I hate everything about
you like I love everything about America
you know like but you know and and we
were like that look we were
protectionist rolling into World War I
it's you know we built literally the
greatest economy the world has ever
known and then after World War II I
think we had a pretty clear idea of who
we were right so what happened Marxist
took over the universities neoliberalism
I mean just destroying the United States
rolling through the' 60s '70s and so
forth and
now as we were just talking about this
um Israeli Palestinian
conflict it's been very interesting
because it's literally like in a
conflict you know think about World War
I where they send up a flare and you can
see where everybody is right now we're
seeing where everybody is like the
universities The Faculty everybody and
it's worse than I think than most people
thought it was well the universities are
about to lose a ton of money more and
more professors are refusing to back
down and so these big donors are like
we're not giving you money anymore yeah
good yeah they let them collapse I was
in those colleges teaching for too long
I saw I saw like Marxist teaching the
kids you know why those colleges
studying for too long and in New York
right where as as worse as it could
possibly be but yeah I I really do think
the the universities are the big problem
of where our identity started to erode I
don't think it's universities I think
it's social media I think I think social
media cated it but I think a lot of
really bad people who were actual like
Marxist like people in The Weather
Underground who are terrorists domestic
terrorists then got out of jail pardoned
by people like Clinton you know went
into Professor became professors and
then taught you know Marxism I've had
this debate 50 billion times and there
are a lot of ideologies in universities
and just because one we know of now
doesn't mean that it's the cause of it
it just means it existed in universities
right and this is why we thought that as
soon as these kids got out of college
have a cold wakeup call but here's so
let's let's put it this way let's say
there's the greater world and there's
University World University world is
woke these kids graduate from college
from woke professors they should be
thrown into a capitalist world that
chews them up and spits them out no
something else happened those kids
commanded power because there were a lot
of them no because of social media
because the kids would go on and send 50
50 emails they would then start spamming
and McDonald's would panic and these
corporations would panic and be like
what's happening why are we being
attacked for this if there was no social
media media apparatus these kids would
never get on TV to complain about
anything they would never come out and
say we think this company is racist
because they did X or Y the people who
run the company would be like they they
they'd go to the big media corporations
and say don't have those people on on
your show and they'd be marginalized but
social media gave them a free platform
and it uh the algorithms incentivized
intersectionality in far-left politics
because more keywords means more clicks
they made more money from it now when
you've got big corporations going to
these Brands they're going to say look
we use Google ads
our our principal customers are a whole
bunch of small restaurants we don't care
we're going to run the article calling
you racist because it's going to make us
a million dollars and the way I see it
is a social media is an extension of the
Marxism they learned in schools where
they were taught like the culture
Revolution was good you know at least
what I'm hearing and then they see the
social media as a struggle session where
they can so the issue is all the other
ideologies that exist did not get that
boost and they're in colleges as well
right and it's because social media
algorithms they take what is socially
acceptable plus whatever generates the
most keywords possible
which of course is going to be racism
social justice Etc so if they if they
started making videos that were Pro
white nationalism those would be deemed
socially unacceptable by big Brands and
otherwise it doesn't doesn't happen
Facebook doesn't want to be associated
with it so they create algorithms that
promote far-left politics which is why
Twitter went from the Free Speech wing
of the Free Speech party into you can't
misgender people it's against the rules
social media was promoting these things
Jack dorsy was a free speech absolutist
until he started getting attacked by by
by uh activists but I I I I'll simplify
because I do want to move on to the next
story none of this could would would
exist or break through into the
mainstream were it not for social media
platforms allowing or or incentivizing
companies to do it example mike.com
started off as Pro Ron Paul and then
turned into far-left wokeness it's not
because the universities made it happen
it's because social media algorithms
created a monetary course for any new
blog and it was PL painly obvious that
Ron Paul was not making you money
wokeness was thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net